Behati Prinsloo is pregnancy goals  showing off her growing baby bump and  yet another bikini selfie but Adam  Levine and his pregnant wife have a  friend from The Voice who is also  expecting no not Gwen Stefani but oddly  enough her country crooner boyfriend is  dealing with pregnancy rumors Adam  shared this cute photo of Blake Shelton  and his expectant wife showing off their  bellies in the caption he wrote met  these two sweet pregnant ladies today  good luck Blake Shelton and Behati  earlier this month or maroon 5 singer  shared an equally hilarious Instagram  pic with the supermodel revealing in his  post quote week 20 and I'm finally  poppin hashtag I'm pregnant too I'm  ready to be a done Levene's fellow voice  coach also joked to et in April that  he's also excited to see his pal become  a father I'm looking forward to Adam  actually having to wake up before noon  or 1 o'clock for the first time in his  life took you know go change the diaper